Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast, but Monday,
March 13th, 2017 what's going on?
how are you ?
How are you, you know what? I asked you that every week. How are but this,
did you know this Monday I would really like to know how are you?
What's going on Mandy? What's going on with you? You're,
you're scaring me.
Okay.
You know, that's the type of shit you can do when you're abroad,
but if you're a guy, you can't do that. You can't be like, Mike,
what's going on with me? What's going on? What's going on with you?
You're scaring me. You know? It was just taken by both his hands.
MMM. [inaudible]
all right. I've got an hour here to do and I gotta be honest with you.
I don't have shit to say because my life has become very compartmentalized.
Being a dad here. Daddy. Hello? Oh,
she's asleep downstairs, man. She's fucking awesome.
Anybody who says that being a parent is hard is a fucking pussy. You know?
I'm not saying that's not tedious.
I'm not say saying it's not like walking around with a little fucking Kettlebell
all day long. You know, especially if you fucked up one of your rotator cuffs.
I've got to keep her in close in the right hand side, you know,
keep her in tight. Tiki barber, don't fumble.
Um,
but uh, we just sit around. We uh, listen a lot of music with her.
I was listening to fucking, um, there was,
I listened to yesterday just like they called Mulch shop oldies.
It's basically like doo-wop from the 1950s and I kind of settled on that channel
and after a while I wanted to turn the channel,
but I couldn't because she was sleeping and the remote was across the table once
a month, say fall asleep dude. It's just like, you know,
I don't care what position you're in,
you're not moving cause if fucking sleeping, right.
So I just sat there and listened to on a loop to all this
Diana, Diana [inaudible].
But, but, but, but, but, but they're slowly going out of my fucking mind.
Do ops great for about four songs in a row.
And then it just becomes the same song over and over and fuck it over again.
Um,
I was listening to that shit for like fucking like an hour and like half of
those songs have been in Scorsese movies. You know,
it's always like some guy's name and then the name of a card, you know,
so and so in the Fleetwood something,
something in the Belmonts Dion and the Belmonts. You got to love them.
Miss still fucking great.
Okay.
You know, the wanderer,
that fucking song is so applicable to anybody who didn't get married.
You're in your forties. Yeah.
Well on a tablet guy who will never settle down and makes you feel great about
the choice you made until the, you know, you realize he sang it in his twenties
and you're like, oh fuck, what was that other one?
You talk too much. You talk too much.
You were re meet a dead. You talk too much. At least as you even worry. My pet,
it's just like they can't be the fucking line, but they played it twice. Um,
speaking of talking too much, just what the fuck I do on this podcast. Um, oh,
I know what I can, I know what, we actually had a date night.
This is how much of a fucking dad and becoming, you know,
still playing drums, you know, schedule a helicopter, uh,
thing. So, you know, I'm still trying to keep the hobbies going,
but they're there. They're starting to wobble on the sticks here. So, um,
we were watching a commercial the other day. No, you're watching.
We'll ah, Barchan um, the other day and um,
they always get to the fucking,
the last prize and we'll fortunate it's so fucked in a touristy cheap.
First of all,
you're basically spending this giant roulette wheel and even on the real wetland
roulette wheel, they got, you know, green zero in the double green zero.
And just that alone, that alone will completely fuck you over.
Now obviously you guys hopefully listen to podcasts long enough to know that I
am not a mathematician, so I cannot explain why,
but just having those two will fuck you over.
Okay.
But what's her face is the, uh, we were fortunate to got like fucking,
I swear to God, it's like two or three bankruptcy, lose a turn,
just constantly,
every two seconds you just see that fucking reverse flute thing or they go
bankrupt and then it comes to their big price.
When they try to act like dig enough, they,
they're going to throw down some goddamn cash. The last one,
it's so fucking difficult. Well, we're going to guess some letters for you.
We're going to get some letters for you. Let me get some letters for me.
You know the fucking answer.
And they act like it's weird when only like one letter.
They only guess one letter. Right. Then if you'd be like, okay, give me,
give me three fucking letters in a vow,
p m f l a and then it's always like,
great guesses, but you're not gonna like this feeling. I got one letter.
It's just like, you know, do the best you can. They always fuck them over.
But this lady, this lady,
she actually did okay and she won the prize. She didn't do okay.
She fucking crushed it. I came in and said,
keep your hands to yourself or something like that was solving like, no,
this is a phrase like who would ever come up with that on a fucking game show?
Keep your hands to yourself with something on that level.
It's like semi aggressive slash you know date rapey and it's on a fucking game
show and she somehow got it. There is a point at the end of this, right,
and she ends up winning this fucking to sita, some sort of Mazda or some shit.
Not a Miyata. I don't know what the fuck it was. Suzuki,
I have no fucking idea.
It was a two seat sports car and I'm
immediately, my first thought was I looked at neo is just like,
you can't get a kid in there. And then she laughed. She's like, ah,
look at you becoming a dad. And I'm like, No God, I'm still young and cool.
But she was right. You know, not becoming a dad.
I am a Goddamn dare, but I'm not,
I'm not going to be one of those Douchey dads that talks about how foe parents
who talks about how fucking difficult their life is, it's fucking awesome.
But having a kid when you're in your twenties and you're broke sucks,
you know,
but when you travel in the country and they're paying your money that talk about
your decks and do fucking sh dicks talking about your deck and do shit jokes,
it's not that bad. I'm only on the road like six days a fucking month.
You know,
as I flying at night early to go watch the fucking Bruins or Celtics or some
shit, if our schedules line up, um,
uh, that, that I'm here and she's cool as shit. Man. She doesn't really cry.
She only cries, you know, you know, it needs a diaper. Chains wants to be held,
you know, hungry. Other than that, she totally chills.
She's met a bunch of people. She doesn't freak out with strangers.
One of the best compliments. I got it. She's like, oh, your kid's really a,
there's a really relaxed, healthy baby. You know what I mean?
Which I'm fucking cite cause that's what I want and obviously healthy,
but I want to fucking chill baby. I don't want like,
I basically don't want my kid to be like me.
That's why I got to keep up with this meditating because I didn't do it for a
minute. And though, oh the old gray mare,
she a I've started fucking going back to what the fuck I was,
you know, like I fucking, uh, I was trying to, you know,
sneak out of the bedroom cause I was going to go work out cause I'm a fucking
fat cupcake. Eaton Douche. And um,
Nia just opens her eyes and just goes, could you change it really quick?
I just stopped and I looked at her and I said,
you really need to work on your good mornings. She's like, sorry,
good morning. And even though I was right,
my tone was just, it was way too, you know, I was like that.
Uh, I always say Liam Neeson neon Niamh Leeson lease some,
I don't know, whatever. I I took it too far, which kills me.
That's why I love meditating cause I don't take it too far.
And if I make a point, I'm still right. But when I don't meditate, you know,
I'd basically, I walk around at a six, you know,
like saying 10 is completely losing your shit. I walk around,
I'm just walking down the street with a fucking balloon on my wrist at a six to
a seven. So it's very easy for me to go right to 10 unless I meditate.
Then that backs me down to about four or three, which still is pretty high,
but it's kind of cutting my number almost in half.
But what kills me is when I'm not meditating and I'm up around a six or seven,
you know, it gets to that point, even if I'm right,
my reaction gives them this. There's wiggle room,
you know, some Bill Clinton wiggle room to get the fuck out of it. You know,
some Trump executive order thing to go around some shit. Um,
so, uh, you know, so I gotta I gotta I gotta stay on that type of shit, dude.
Speaking of fucking
Niamh Lisa Niamh listen, why can't it, you know, it's one of those,
fuck if it goes by so fucking quick, you never really even hear it. No Bell.
We all hear it. You don't normally look at, okay,
get this guy's fucking name right. He's great actor here. Niamh
oh no, it's Liam Neeson. His first name's not Liam.
Yes it is. Niamh lease out whatever.
I'll never get that right. I'm never going to get that fucking right. Anyways,
a fucking head of hair on that son of a bitch. Um, anyways,
I saw a fucking great movie this week. So Saturday night, Saturday,
Saturday we go out and uh,
we actually have a date night, so we'll be like, all right,
well go get maybe like dinner and a movie.
What basically turned about appetizer and a drink. And I'm sitting there like,
you know, I'm on the wagon, I can't do it. And he was like, oh,
just fucking have one. So I was like, all right, I'll have one, you know,
still on the wagon, you know,
I'm not like a fucking alcoholic or I just gotta shut the whole thing off.
You know what I mean? So I had one,
I had a cognac of folk and Cognac and I just said, you know,
I just ordered the best one that they had, you know, so it tasted amazing,
but it was also like drinking gasoline so they could only sip it.
And we got like an appetizer and then we just sat there, uh, you know,
shooting the shit. It felt weird cause we hadn't been out together in awhile.
And then we just started talking about our daughter and looking at pictures of
her.
It's like two addicts going out, you know what I mean?
At some point you're going to start talking about blow and how much fun it is.
Um, so then, you know, after that we walked up the street,
we went to the movie theater and, uh, we saw get out,
um, that Jordan Peele fee film. Dude, it was fucking, that was amazing.
You gotta go see it. I know there's, you know, you know,
there's always that movie and he's like, dude, you gotta go fucking see it.
And it doesn't live up to the eye. It lived up to the EIT, man.
It was fucking great. And what I loved,
what I loved about it and what I love about all fucking movies like is it was a
bunch of shit in there that you ha he left you to figure out yourself.
And I saw the movie like two, three days ago, Saturday, that was a Monday,
two days ago. You know, and I keep even, I'm driving,
I'm still thinking about the movie. I was like, Oh fuck,
that was this and this meant that and this is over here.
And this person's ad like, you know, was the perfect length,
the whole thing and the acting. And it was unbelievable. Um,
dude, that fucking guys swear to God, man.
That's like one of the most talented people to come around and a long,
long time, you know,
to be that good at like, you know,
the characters they did on a sketch show and the writing.
And then on top of that,
you can direct them in these kinds of fucking limitless as far as talent goes.
But if you haven't seen it yet before somebody ruins it,
you got to go check it out. All right, there's my, I never do a movie plug,
so there you go. There's one for Ya. Um,
so we ended up going to that thing and uh,
okay.
I remember what the fuck we did after that. I think we just came straight home.
Oh, I know. Walked up to my car and for some reason the fucking lights were on
because cars are so god damn confusing.
Like wherever the fuck my lights used to be was the automatic you just turned
the car on and they fucking come on at night.
Like somehow the light sense night, fucking creepy is that.
And I did the manual one and now that it's on the manual one,
I can't figure out where the fuck to put it.
So now I always have to do it and now I'm like, you know,
but you know it kills me with today's technology is I left those things on,
went and had a drink and an appetizer and then saw like a fucking whatever,
whatever that movies, 90 minutes, hour and 45 minute movie and I came back,
my car still started up back in the day. You are fucked.
Yeah.
Everybody had jumper cables, doe, can you give me a jump?
Do you mind if you can?
Eight body can get me a jump and it was always like the shittiest fucking car
ever. And you're looking at math? Nah Man, a kid, a kid.
Now you could just say no I can't. The big, why not? It's like,
well with today's technology it's pointless for me to ever look under my hood.
I just take it down to the dealer and they deal with everything.
I don't even know where the battery is and I can get and fucking to you. When I,
when I fucking lift up the hood,
I probably have to remove something to get to one of the terminals.
So, I don't know why you're not a member of AAA, but you know,
I don't want it to tell you.
And I leave and I get my car and I drive away from a fellow American.
You understand me do what's going on with the fucking Celtics.
Okay.
You've lost six of their last 11 games that five and six and now the wizards,
the whiz ease on down, ease on down the road hold.
I never really realized that until a buddy of mine has been giving me Shit,
you know,
cause it wizards and been playing well against the Celtics and just playing
great this year.
They slid into a second place and I just keep trashing about the name.
I don't like the bullets is too violent, you know,
which I understand because the city was so violent back in the day, you know,
but to go from being the bullets, which I used to think, you know,
number one with the bullet, that's how I always looked at it.
Or faster than a speeding bullet. Superman Shit. I didn't think like, you know,
the team was embracing gang violence out on the street and was like pro crack.
It's such stupid shit. I fucking hate when they, so then what do they do?
What are the soccer moms fucking political correct.
Police who for some fucking stupid reason think that they're the progressive
people and think that they can just, Oh, we'll change words if we change words.
It changes to perception. Now it doesn't. Now it doesn't.
If your parents would dopes racist [inaudible] that's what the fuck your kid's
going to be. That's it. Unless your kid is lucky enough to win,
interact with somebody within the group that your parents used to fucking trash,
then maybe you got some day like you don't just change a word and it's this
fairy dust that sprinkles over somebody's heart and you change the thought
itself. Fucking dumb.
All it did was just become a way to lose your job because you said the wrong
fucking word. And then what? The person who uses the word,
then they realize it after they lose the job. Oh,
now I'm not racist or homophobic and so fucking dumb.
So they've gone right down to these stupid fucking team names.
I love how they changed the bullets, but not the Redskins.
You know, the B got you. Get like the fucking, uh, thank them.
If they ever changed the Redskins, it'd be like, yeah, I get that. I get that.
Like the Indians, you know, it's like, all right. You know,
we weren't from fucking, we weren't, you know,
Columbus didn't understand that there was a real world.
If this shit's even real, who the fuck knows? There was no tape recorders.
This guy didn't have a fucking diary,
but other story was told was that he was like, no man,
the world is fucking round.
This guy had the balls.
Scott had the fucking balls to,
to start going towards where they thought you'd go off the edge of the earth in
a fucking boat. You know,
I don't know why the water makes it more scary, but you know,
if anybody just sat around thought about Saturday,
thought the world is fucking flat. Um,
how is it the water just running off the edges here?
Did they not have counters and sinks? I guess they didn't.
Did they have plumbing at that point? Again, you know, the Romans did
fucking Edens banging each other in the goddamn bathrooms there, whatever.
They eight until he had puke rooms just eat until you fucking puke.
So I would actually think, well, at the very least, even if it is flat,
the fact that there's still water in the ocean,
there's gotta be land on the other side holding it in. Right?
Okay.
But not all, Christopher Columbus, not all Chrissy. He was like, no, fuck damn,
I'm going to get to the West indies, whatever the fuck it was,
and we'd get to India.
I'm going the other way.
Me fucking sky the balls to sell out that way. Sales out that way.
And then he thinks so fuck yeah, these people must be Indian.
You know, that's just sort of like, oh,
are you Arab? I thought you were Italian. I mean,
it's at that level of offensive, like, I mean,
would you really get that offended? Like, no, I'm fucking Arab.
How dare you be like, well, what do you got to get to? Talions you can't, sorry.
Yeah. Anyways. Um,
speaking of which,
I don't understand all these people going into to ancestry.com why you would go
to a fucking website and let them take a swab of your saliva.
How fucking dumb are people? Oh my God,
I didn't realize, you know, I'm also Swahili
and whenever them fun, why always pick Swahili? I was thinking of Romania.
I didn't understand that was so, so Hungarian. Great.
Now I know why I like Goulash one eighth of the time.
At this point you're so fucking far removed and I don't understand why people
are sitting there acting like there's any sort of culture there isn't all right.
It's just like what I saw in the Greater Phoenix area.
There's a new patch of land, you know, you fucking clear it out.
You put a bunch of houses down and then you slammed down
a fucking strip mall. Sorry, I've got to do this podcast before.
Okay.
But daughter wakes up here. Um, yeah,
they slept on a fucking strip mall and then you just continue to progress that.
That's basically, you know, then there's a cheesecake factory.
They get a frozen yogurt place and that's what it's become. Okay. There's no,
there's no culture left. Is there? I mean that is the culture.
I just sounds like one of the douchey talk show right now,
there is no culture and this is what needs to stop.
We have to stop these strip malls. All right. Do you have a solution? No,
I don't. I just don't like cvs anchored strip malls.
Okay.
There was a bunch of people out the other day, you know,
you know when you just have like shit to do like a Saturday, right. And uh,
it's rained a bunch when we were out here and some fucking idiot politicians
said the drought's over. It's like, no it isn't. It's never over.
It's just in a good right now. When is it going to rain again?
You don't know snow.
You gonna let people go back to taking long fucking showers.
I never do that out here. I shut,
I turn on and shut off the water like fucking five times when I take a shower,
turn it on, you know, get yourself wet, you know, and then you shut it off,
such yourself up. Then you turn it back on, wrench itself off.
You shut it off and that's it.
So it says standing there under the cascading water, you know,
like he's some sort of God.
Um,
but I like to think a lot of people try to do that.
At least my wife does and she fucking turns a thing on his fucking walking
around. You know, she's one of those chill people.
She hasn't, she hasn't think about shit like that. You know?
I guess what I'm trying to say is I'm a better person than my wife and I don't
know how to bring that up. If you guys know a good way to word it.
Like how can I basically say, you know what it is honey.
I guess at the end of the day I'm just,
I'm just a better person than you are.
I just already pictured her rolling her eyes anyways.
I'm the fuck was my point. All right. Yeah, so Indians. Okay.
That's like fucking,
that's almost kind of funny. Like, no, you're fucking dope.
You like 6,000 miles away from what you think you are.
I guess it was probably funny at first.
So he started chopping people's arms off cause they couldn't fucking get some
gold for the holes in his teeth.
And who the fuck am I to say what's offensive? What it,
but you would think that red skin,
what that would be at the top of the fucking list over bullets, you know,
it was the worst one.
The fact that the Tampa Bay devil rays and now just the race,
you know, that's when you know you got to move. That's when you just sit like,
wait a minute,
are there enough Jesus freaks in this area that the local team has to appease
their, you know, hocus pocus bullshit.
I mean devil rays that isn't that,
is that an actual name of like some sort of sting ray [inaudible]?
I have no idea. Maybe it is. Maybe it is.
All I know is that that guy's first name is Liam.
It sounds too close like lime, like Lyme disease. Um, all right,
devil
ray. Here we go. Yeah.
Let me see here.
All I'm seeing is pictures of fucking sting rays, giant ones with the fucking,
you know, like they're flying through the water.
If somebody can explain to me how that makes you move forward when they make you
go up to this surface. Do these things a fucking gigantic.
They're bad ass.
The good
thing, it's getting air. It's jumping out of the water.
Unless somebody Photoshop it. I've got to go video now.
They just changed it to the race.
We just array incredible flying rays.
So I guess devil ray was the nickname. Protect Your Business Data from,
Oh Jesus Christ. I don't need a commercial. I do the commercials. Not you
on the west coast.
On the west coast is always some fucking English accent and the Shork plus the
BBC. Sorry. Yes.
Feeding [inaudible].
Oh Jesus. What are they showing there? And I somehow I got a fucking Pelican
20 abnormally large animals that actually exist.
This is how you fucking go down aisle. You go down just like a a,
what do they call it? The go down in the fucking rabbit hole.
Let's see. Come on, man. Oh, that was a,
still was a school of I'm an asshole. Right? Is it fucking got good?
Jesus. Those things are ugly as Shit, Huh?
All right, so they're dead. They're in a helicopter.
I imagine they're flying over this, uh,
this whole school of them. It's like a fucking devil, ray or G.
That's why I bet the other ones, they're like more like a, what do they,
what do you call it? If you're just monogamous? These things are out here.
Fucking the shit out of each other and the local Jesus freaks down and
Clearwater, Florida. They couldn't have it. Nah,
they fly out of the fucking water. They're a two graceful with the,
with the landing there. All right,
I'll repost that fucking video in case you want to watch that while you listen
to me ramble about it.
Um,
yeah, they changed it to the rays, the Tampa Bay rays,
the Tampa Bay devil rays. Two syllables. Two syllables.
Okay. They went from four,
four time to three four they turned their fucking team into a Wallace.
Oh, Bunco.
I Dunno. I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about. Can I, can I read?
Can I read you? Get you guys want you to listen to me? Read out loud.
Hey everybody.
It's time to feel better about your f the brain you are blessed with.
Just sit right here.
It's somebody explained to me why it's not at the font I need.
I like a nice fucking 18
font. That's good for me. All right. Oh, dollar shave club, everybody. Oh,
Jesus Christ. There's no reason to use a cheap disposable racy. You stupid cunt.
We'll pay a ridiculously high price for gimmicky, for gimmicky thing.
It's got a laser pointer with 17 blades.
You don't need to do it. Make the smarter choice and join. Do Always Shave club.
Dude. Before Dollar Shave Club,
it was either save money and a painful shave from a disposable like ones they
give away for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving with a piece of glass or pay a fortune for the latest
gimmick. These shaped breakthrough you don't need like a laser chin detector
or has 17 blades is, I told you before,
the sweet spot was two blades, two plates was perfect.
Nothing shaved like the two blade three blade stinks.
That's when it get the gets too big. You can't get underneath.
You knows dollar Shave Club is the best of both worlds.
Worlds a premium shave at a disposable price. Get a close,
smooth shave every time. God Damn it.
If you can't beat the convenience to the price of the club,
I don't know what to fucking tell you. You haven't tried dollar shave club yet.
You're missing out. It's an amazing shave at an affordable price.
If you haven't figured that out yet, like they haven't said at 27 fucking times,
are they saying at one time for every blade you don't need,
there's no smarter choice on the market and right now they're giving away a one
month trial of any of their raises for $1 with free shipping and after that it's
just a few bucks a month. There's no long term commitments, no hidden fees.
You know your girlfriend won't fuck around on you and you can cancel whenever
you want.
Get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar that's dollar shave club.com/bar
oh here's are friends. Oh, here we go. It's sold zip.
[inaudible]
good. How are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
You don't do Yah, but you don't want to admit it to anybody.
So when no one's around you put your head down and your desk,
you quietly cry to yourself wishing that you were a child again.
Your parents would taken you out for an ice cream cause you can't deal with the
pressures of the world. Well, I got it. I got a solution for you.
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
You stupid. Fuck. You want to find the perfect hire?
Okay,
well, yeah,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites and now you can zip
ah,
screwed up.com you can post your job to 200 plus job sites including social
media networks like the Facebook and the Twitter.
All with a single click left that said single Dick fucking perfect with giant
keys. You know, sticking his helmet on the keyboard.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide. Just roll well.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface. No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates. Rate them, judge them,
put them in a box and hire the right person fast.
Nice 10 days. Find out today why zip
[inaudible]
has been used by fortune 100 companies and thousands of small and medium size
businesses. And right now my listeners,
my listeners and anybody else they sold this to can post jobs on ZipRecruiter
for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/berg at
ziprecruiter.com/bird one more time. Try It for free. Go to zip
[inaudible] dot com slash burb all right.
How many more of these fucking things. I got two more left. Go on.
Hang in there. Hang in there with me. It's helix. Everybody.
Helux you're unique. You're special.
No you're not. You're drowning in mediocrity.
What are you going to find your voice?
What are you going to spread your wings like a devil ray?
Come out of the water and deal with your fucking eyeballs and hang out the side
of your fucking head.
Come out of the water and show people who you are and then belly flop back into
it. All right. You're unique. Okay. Yeah. There's something about you I guess.
You know, I guess if I talked to your mother she could find something.
You don't walk like everyone else. Talk like everyone else.
Show Chet or sleep like anyone else.
So why the fuck is your mattress one size fits all they've ever thought about
this cause you haven't. Who the fuck has time to think about this?
Because it truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks.
Jesus Christ is a comb with a couple of who is until now,
go to hell. Exceed like sleep.com answer a few simple questions.
Do a saliva swab and they'll run a three d biomechanical modal modal of your
body through the proprietary algorithms state developed with the help of the
world's leading error, ergonomics and biomechanics experts.
They're going to make a fucking robot.
Yeah,
that's what they're going to do with. They're not going to do this.
I bet helix is going to fucking sell that.
That fucking proprietary algorithm of your God Damn nutsack and next thing you
know,
there's going to be a fucking lifelike robot walking around with an exact
replica of your junk. But I'm going to tell you right now,
you're going to sleep like you never slept before. All right? You know why?
Because Helen's customers helix report at 30% improvement in overall sleep
quality. How they figured that out, I have no idea.
How can you fucking take notes while you're sleeping? I guess when they wake up,
they feel you want,
if you wanna improve your fucking sleep by 30% lay off the booze.
You're fucking drunk. Save money on the mattress. If you lay off the bar,
maybe this is the, this is the fucking mattress for drunks.
So as much as you're hung over, you offset it with this great mattress,
I'm going to get one of these things. And for couples, Oh,
now they're getting freaky. They customize each side of the mattress. Oh,
they went the other way. They customize each side of the mattress. You know,
that's for someone in a loveless marriage.
If you notice that your side of the bed isn't, as you know,
if you're annoyed that your wife likes soft magic, that's fucking over.
And I liked the hard mattress. That's it.
Just go start sleeping on the couch and when she goes to bed, you know,
start trolling for Internet, Pussy, social media, you know,
that's what you should do. But anyways,
your mattress arrives at your door in about a week when it's shipping is 100%
free. That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helix sleep.
Hellings you have a hundred nights to try it out, grouse.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free this stuff day and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
I always picture Mr. White and Jesse Pinkman showing up in a hazmat suit.
You know, we're here for your mattress
and you won't even touch it at that point yet. It's in the back.
Good luck to you. Go to helix, sleep.com/burn get $50 off your order.
That's Helen's sleep.com/berg one more time. Hey, he looks
sleek.com/burb lastly, but not leastly.
MVMT watches the company started by two broke college kids.
I've never understood that line. Hey, we're flat broke.
You want to start a company? Absolutely. Um,
they wanted to wear stylish watches, but they couldn't afford them.
So they started their own watch company.
Did they just solve the homeless problem? You know,
I'm fucking living outside. I can't afford a house.
So I went out and I bought one no more homeless guy.
How is this like how you started built a following launched into a podcast,
youtube, radio, Cetera? Oh, I guess on somebody. Oh,
you know what this reminds me of when I started out like a comedian.
I didn't have any jokes, so I,
I sat down and wrote something that I went up on stage at a,
you know, I did. Okay. Does that remind you of watches?
All right. Little bit. Watch it started at just $95 at a department store.
Oh, I'm sorry. 95 movement watches.
start@justninetyfivedollarsdot.dot added department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks. Movement watches.
Well, move it figured out that by selling online,
they were able to cut out the middleman and retail markedly. He figured it out.
Everybody knows that Jesus Christ,
these guys are changes providing the best quality price. Classic design,
quality construction and minimalism.
Over 1 million watches sold in over 160 countries.
Okay?
That's almost 50,000 watches in each country.
Get 15% off today with free watches and free returns by going to movement
watches.com/berg this watch has a really clean design. Seriously,
I've been getting compliments ever since I put mine on.
Now is the time to step up your watch game. Go to movement,
watches.com/bird join the movement. Now what?
Fuck would they say that I'm walking around wearing them?
I would wear that if I was like 20 years younger.
Okay.
Let me tell you something.
If you're in your late fucking forties and you can't afford a fucking,
you can't afford a decent one. Decent Watch. Cause I don't,
I don't go for the flesh. You know what I mean? I don't,
I don't understand that, that fuck. I mean, I get it.
I guess I get that Rolex thing.
Yeah,
that hacky thing. I got a Rolex. As you can see, I've made my dreams come true.
I'm a man in the world. I know there's a lot of guys out there.
You know my dad always said a man shit on a nice watch.
What else did he say? I get the fuck Outta here. I'm taking a shit. You know?
What else did he say that was so fucking deep baby? You know, maybe at a nice,
calm, relaxed, relaxing person in your life.
Maybe you did. I'm always jealous of that. When I see like come families,
they gotta be bored shitless though. There's going to be, you know what?
I bet I would actually be willing to guess that the child that is more likely
to just go fucking nuts. You know what I mean? Take out the family car,
you know, throw a hatchet over somebody's head. It's going to come from a comm
family after a while. That's stupid. No, it isn't.
I'm just saying it's possible. Just the fucking monotony of it.
Like Kevin go to Disneyland.
Yeah,
and you fucking worn out and then you just started hearing.
It's a small world and it just keeps going over and over again and you slowly
feel yourself like losing your sanity.
That right there is why I don't believe in heaven or hell.
You know what I mean? I just don't believe in it.
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
You know,
like if heaven was, if it was just having the whole fucking time,
heaven would eventually become hell because it would just be so fucking nice and
everybody would just be walking around. Isn't this great? Oh my God. It's scary.
Can you believe how great this is? This is just fucking great.
It's probably like every fucking day,
and then at some point you're gonna be like, ah, it's fucking gray.
You know?
Like what do you do
for the rest of your fucking life?
You just sitting there and it's always the same. It's just awesome.
It never rains. There's no disappointments, there's no challenges.
There's no funny stories to tell anymore. Hey,
you remember, remember, remember that time when it was awesome? Yeah.
It's always awesome. Right?
Then if you're in hell, I'm on fire. No, I'm fine. I got them. I'm fine.
I'm fine. After a while, you know? Um, yeah, I'm on fire.
I can't yell anymore. This is just become normal.
I don't even remember what my fucking life was like before I got here.
I Dunno. I guess how well you can actually see how that would suck.
I don't get heaven.
Okay.
I don't want to fucking be like, you know, at some point somebody has to happen.
I'm as I'm riding around in my fucking all angel white bicycle.
At some point you got to get a flat right
then immediately somebody would be there to help and help you out.
They'd be saying a bunch of Nice Shit to you. I would slowly just start crying.
We just whispered at some points. We like cheeses [inaudible]
I know. It's just weird. I understand and I'm not,
I'm not trying to be that guy who's not appreciative, but could you just say no,
cause you just call me a cunt or something?
Could you fucking just slap me with your sandal?
You know? Can you just imagine the look on his face as he just sits there?
You know, not saying anything.
As you talk yourself into a corner and she's sort of looking at, you know,
people look at you when they go from one eye to the other, right? I,
you left it right out your left eye and you like,
this is trying to get in my head right now.
The son of God is trying to get in my fucking head.
Then you got to explain that to the boss's son.
Why you don't like heaven? Not that you don't like it, but it's just like, can,
can you make it rain every once in awhile?
Can it be that dog that's just fucking barking right as I'm going to sleep?
Come. Can we just have that?
Does every fucking dog have to behave itself?
Why can't I say that word? Jesus. Why can't I say that word? My disruptive.
What are you gonna do now? Send me down to hell. It's over.
I already passed the test. All right.
Can somebody be annoyed with fucking something up here? Look at everybody.
Look at it. Well, these fucking goddamn smiles on the faces.
It's creepy. Jesus. I don't know.
Would you want to fucking be like, it's like you joined a cult.
Hello.
All of these fucking, you know what I mean? If I was running shit,
I wouldn't make religion illegal. It would just be fucking,
I would just take it all away from everybody. You know,
I, that's what I would do. I would have, I would have a fucking crew, robots,
you know, to infiltrate every fucking religion.
And then at, when I made it illegal,
they would join the radicalized people in every group. Right.
And then they would just wipe them all out, you know?
And then you'd have to listen to the whining and the crying of people that
remembered fucking religion and all. He just,
he just take the whole fucking thing away. And the new religion is, hey,
I don't know what the fuck happens after you die,
you know? But you know, let's be nice to each other.
And then that's it. Gay, no walking on water. No,
never running out of fish pot and C's.
I don't know about anybody else's religion. I don't know what the fuck,
but I know there's always some fucking crazy thing that, you know,
didn't happen and everybody acts like it happened.
It didn't happen.
Who is painted on a fucking cave wall and somebody elaborated on it?
I Dunno. I get rid of all personally, I'm just,
I'm just talking for myself personally. I would get rid of it. Um, be,
by the way, guess what? I'm doing on March 29th out here in Los Angeles.
All right. If you are, um,
if you're in Los Angeles and you're a guns and roses fan and you like reading
their books about the band, I've read every fucking one of them.
Um, I read slashes, I read Stephen Adler's,
I read a the kid from canter's.
Do, you know, knew the band, took all the pictures.
I have that fucking book and uh, recently, I don't know,
I dunno when she put it out, but Deanna Adler,
Steven Adler's mom wrote a book, sweet child of mine. And um,
especially if you, if you, you should read this, you should read Steven's first.
You know,
you get his version of the hell he went through was an addict and then you get
his mother's version, which is unbelievable.
And you know what would be fucking amazing is if you could go down
and meet her at a book signing it bonds the Nobel at the Grove on March 29th I
believe it starts at 7:00 PM and you go down there and you could fucking meet
the mother the best fucking one of the best drummers of the 80s my personal
opinion, you know,
it'd be even more fucking amazing is if all of them came on my podcast and I got
to interview them. Oh,
Sarah's special Monday morning podcast coming up this week.
Wouldn't that be incredible? What?
What would it be like if Stephen Adler and you guys all know how much I fucking
love him,
his mother DNA Adler and then that brother Jamie Adler all came on my fucking
podcasts. What would that be like? We'll be out.
Like if they all came on at the same time and they were this big happy family
that just sat there interrupting each other and you felt like you were at their
fucking dinner table,
how fucking cool would that be if I did a podcast like that? Well
it's going to happen. It already happened. I already recorded it. And um,
I'll wait till you guys listen to it. But, um,
I had so much fun with them and uh,
their mother is an absolute salt of the earth sweetheart and she says a book
signing and um,
she's all excited slash nervous that no one's going to show up, you know,
as you know, say when I put out a special, what if nobody watches it. So, um,
I'm going to be hyping this, um, right up until March 29th.
Um, it'd be such a great thing if there was a bunch of people down there.
I'm going to be down there standing in line with the rest of you. Uh,
probably get down there. I Dunno, probably like around, uh, eight ish.
I think it starts at like seven,
but I'll be down there around h just cause I get, I get some fucking thing.
I'm taping right before, but um, yeah, I did a special podcast.
I got to meet Steven Adler and I'm still fucking freaking out. And, uh,
and I'll,
I'll wait till you guys listen to the interview and then I'll tell you all the
fucking cool stories. All right, here we go. Let's, let's plow ahead here. Oh,
my Bruins beat the fucking fly. Oh,
at that little fucking prayer of a shot at the end. Not a prayer,
just put it on net. Some out found its way to the back of the net Bruins.
Pick up a huge two points, Bruins it playing great. Um,
and as our, the Canadians, which, um, I don't like the Canadians,
but I'm happy for Khloe, Julian, you know, and uh, I'm actually, you know what,
I think the Bruins might've been right to make a move at this point. I think,
uh, it's just one of those things with coaching after a while,
even if the person is great, even if they one your cup, it's just,
it's just part of coaching at some point they just show you the door. But, um,
we're playing great. We look a lot better than we did. So I think maybe both.
It's worked out in the fucking Canadians of playing better with Khloe. Julian,
all my friends in this business who I had fans,
they keep texting me saying that they love and the guy,
so I guess it worked out for everybody. So there you go. And closed.
Went from original fucking six to original six. Um,
there you go. All right. So anyways, let's plow ahead here. Um,
let's read some of the, uh, some of the fucking,
whenever you call them for this week. The, uh, the questions. All right,
DDP Yoga. Hey Bill, first of all,
thank you very much for your consistently amazing podcasts. Well,
thank you for listening. Thank you for doing what you do,
sir. Or ma'am. I absolutely love it to be honest with you.
I feel like it's getting, it's,
I feel like getting it for free is too much.
I'd gladly pay five to 10 bucks a month for all the content you're releasing.
You don't need to do that. I'm fucking, I'm doing great with the advertising.
You know,
that's why I fuck around during the advertising because that's how I fucking
make money.
But I know you guys are going to fast forward through it and unless I keep
pepper in it with Fox and [inaudible], that's it. It's a very simple formula.
Anyhow, he said,
I want to get in touch and address yourself proclaimed dad bod.
Have you ever heard of or looked into DDP Yoga?
Uh, if not, maybe the name Diamond Dallas page rings,
a bell, former WC w rest wrestler and all around.
Great Guy. After leaving the wrestling business,
he devoted himself to getting his body back in peak condition.
Even through wrassling, even though wrassling is his quote fake,
it definitely takes a toll. Yeah, they beat the shit out of their bodies.
Long story short,
he went from being a guy who wouldn't be caught dead in a yoga studio to trying
it after all else.
Failed to develop his own system in helping thousands of people completely
revitalize their lives. And I can tell you from personal experience,
it's fucking great. No bullshit, no fluff, no one's structures, structures,
calmly whispering about Chakra alignment.
So you say Chakra Chakra.
It's about consistently performing the physical and mental exercises that will
have you operating at your best. This is a commercial healing,
nagging aches and pains, increasing your endurance, gaining mental clarity,
et cetera. Like I said, no fluff.
He used the video that got me to take a chance on it.
It's not too late for you Billy. I hope you'll check it out.
Thanks again for the Goddamn podcast.
All the best to you and your family that actually read like a commercial.
But you know what, I don't give a shit.
It's a physical fitness thing and so many people have taken yoga and done in a
different way. You know cause there is that thing.
If you really like a wound up psycho to go into a yoga class and the tone with
which that they speak is a little jarring, you know,
to be in your car going,
oh you fucking caught the lightest way you could have made it
to then being like how is everyone feeling today?
I know the traffic was kind of bad. I hope.
I hope you're not bringing that energy in here. Is it slowly walking around,
lighting these smelly fucking things, you know,
and as they're talking, the person next to you just goes
and immediately you just want to like, I dunno,
just slowly roll up your mat and just walk out. Like I can't,
like I get it, I get, I need to chill out, but I can't feel like,
you know, you know what,
it just becomes like this asexual thing where everybody's just kinda like,
hey man, we just kinda, you know, everybody's just like, we're all like one,
you know, we like plants. Um,
that's a little fucking jarring. I'll give it a shot.
I've actually been meaning to do it cause I keep having setbacks with my fucking
shoulder. Um, which is really frustrating. But, um,
most of it is diet. So, uh, whenever I get in shape,
the first thing I do is I cut out the booze and, um, all I really need to,
I need to go like 46 days without any booze.
Even just having that one cognac didn't really do anything.
Like I had the one and then Amelia, my body's like, hey,
why don't we have 15 more? But I had to go to the movie and then I was fine.
Um, and then the second I'm in there and the buzz starts to wear off.
I think I'll thank God I didn't have 15 more. Not to mention I gotta drive.
Right. Um, I'm going to give it a shot. I just think if I did yoga,
I'd have to do in the morning before the little one wakes up. Um,
she's so fucking awesome, dude. I'm telling you right. You'll never regret it.
I guess. You know, when you get it,
if you have a kid with somebody that you're not love with,
I guess that that would suck. But at the end of the day, the kids still awesome.
It's a hell of a door price, I'll tell you that, right? Oh, I'll tell Ya.
Alright. Trans wrestling. Hey there. I'm already gonna Watch this.
If this is what I think it is a, that Billy boo a,
did you hear the story about the Trans girl going through home hormone
treatment? Who was still wrestling girls in high school.
His slash her defense is that it's a low dose of testosterone and it does not
allow for any competitive advantage.
Wait a minute, isn't that what HGH is? That's human growth hormone.
Well, I guess they don't took human growth hormone. I don't know.
I don't know what kind of hormones they take. Um, having said that,
I'm not sure I'd let my daughter wrassle a girl who had any edge at all.
Even if it's a tiny bit of extra strength.
It could be the difference in breaking a bone. Thoughts.
Would you let your daughter wrestle in that situation? Uh, yeah. Yeah,
I would then they're to break a fucking bone, you know what I mean?
How many times did people break a bone in wrestling? Does that really happen?
They just fucking on each other the whole time. It's like a,
you know, like that official level shit. Not that, not the fun shit,
the stone cold shit that the, the actual official college shit. It's like a,
it's like competitive spooning. You know what I mean?
It's like one person is trying to spoon with the other person and the other
person's like, I want to be this, the Spooner and not the spoonie.
That's basically what's going on. They don't really, you know? No,
I wouldn't be concerned about that. Yeah.
I'm one of those debts. Well, the kids crying go away.
You know? She's already half a guy. I'd be driving my ads as far as I know.
She's still a girl, so suck it up.
You want to be the best. Well then you got to wrestle half of two.
Oh, I don't want to hear another word out of you. I'd be like dead.
Whether you embrace the opportunity to be like, well, here we go.
If this is actually a fucking advantage,
all this is going to do is make me better. You know what I mean?
And then he could go up there and give you a record 27 and no against hundred
percent checks in what? In?
To get someone who's half a dude, right. You've got to embrace it.
I mean, what does that person supposed to do?
There's not enough fucking people that are going through what the fuck she's
going through to fit any of the side.
You know,
I think it's, I think it's a cool thing. Fucking that won't gives a shit. Look,
there's already gonna be that fucking monster anyways. Some,
some woman's gonna walk in there and it's just going to be blessed with frontier
strength. You know what I mean?
Chopping wood strength is going to be that person anyways.
Um,
I mean, I guess if she was actually,
if she was trying to get a scholarship in a loss could potentially affect it.
Um, maybe,
but I gotta be honest with you. I think I'm,
I dunno, I would,
as a father I'd be like [inaudible] see how you do this is actually an
advantage. This is a great fucking opportunity to, you become a,
for you to become a better wrestler. There's no money on the line.
Who gives a fuck? Let's go.
Let me tell you something, brother.
Come this Saturday when my daughter wrestles a good stat. Half a dude.
What are you going to do when these pythons run wild on your life?
I get up for it. I wouldn't give a shit. Fuck it. Um, yeah.
Many guy in Europe.
Okay,
so persons from Yemen.
Yemeni. Yeah, Yemen and e.
How the fuck do you say that guy in Europe. All right. Hey Bill,
I'm a Yemeni guy who is bad. I hope I'm saying that right. No disrespect here.
Who's been living in Europe for the past six fucking years?
Okay.
Although everything is going all right.
I want to ask your advice because I can relate to your personality.
Hang on a second, sir. Or ma'am, I want to fucking figure out where the fuck.
I'm assuming you're from Yemen.
What is Yemeni?
What is a Yamini whom to whom is he is a Yemenite.
Oh yeah. Why did that all disappear?
What is a Yemeni?
Come on.
Alright. Relating to Yemen or its people. Holy Shit. I was right.
Okay.
That's a nice flag. I got a nice flag. I like just the three bars.
I'm a big three bar flag guy. France, Italy,
Ireland, Yemen. I'm all right.
Okay.
What do you guys think of the new Russian flag? I kinda liked the old one.
The old one was this shit all red with that sickle. I thought the,
I thought that that one was fucking dope. The new ones. All right.
What does it red, white and blue. Holy Shit. They got the same colors as us.
Is that what it, is it something like that? I don't know.
I was watching this whole thing about flatten your Putin poison in these guys
and shit. Allegedly. I have no idea.
So watching it on 60 minutes so it's got to be true, right? Tick, tick, tick,
tick, tick. All right. You have any guy in your bar?
I've been over there for the last six fucking years.
I want to ask you a question because I can relate to personally.
My family has been living in a war zone in Yemen for the past two years.
Our old house,
our old house there was bombed and my father was inside,
but the lucky bastard came out without a scratch.
I miss them and wish I could help them, but that's kind of not possible now.
All right before the, I already feel like this is going to be way over my head.
Before that I lost some good old friends that I knew for more than 10 years
because of some stupid incidents was beaten by a gang of more than 15 men in
Malaysia on a trip there for no reason.
And my two year ex-girlfriend at the time cheated on me with their current
boyfriend. Is this fucking amazing?
This guy's from the other side of the planet and in seek sex, same shit,
gang violence and you fucking girl got sick of you and fucking bang.
Somebody else
cheated on me with her current boyfriend while I was on that trip,
I guess to Malaysia and didn't have the decency to break up with me before that.
She was my first, uh, you know, what are you going to do? People are young,
they don't know how to break up.
So they wait till you go to Malaysia and they fucked somebody.
Me that this is a time honored tradition of how to break up with somebody.
All right. So if you, with your first love, what have we learned?
Do not go by yourself to Malaysia.
I don't know how many times I brought that up on this podcast.
You cannot go to fucking Malaysia. All right. I just graduated from college.
I have a beautiful girlfriend, which I love and feel blessed with what I have.
I know that I an asshole at certain moments in my life,
but I have changed a long time ago and I'm still trying to be more honest,
clear and focused. Well, welcome to the club, sir.
I'm currently looking for a job in Germany and we'll try to apply after that for
a German passport,
which will make my life much easier and allow me to start a company and sustain
myself without being dependent on others. Exactly.
You want to work for yourself.
I know that you have lived certain moments in your life where you are faced by
challenged, faced with challenges that might be taught a lesson,
but at the same time left a mark on your self confidence.
How did you empower yourself and what advice would you give a young man like me
confronting life's challenges? That's it. Fuck face.
Congratulations on your baby and fuck you.
Now there's a guy, okay,
who speaks at least three languages and still is able to break balls.
Isn't that amazing? He's probably speaks Yemeni, Yemenite,
Yemen, Asian, whatever the fuck he speaks. Right? He's knows that one.
He's in Germany, so he's got to speak that language on via you in this space.
Right. And he can also speak English.
Um,
how did I empower myself?
Uh Huh.
I used to just say shit out loud to myself. You know,
when I would feel the dark cloud of doubt coming in, I would just,
you know, it took me a while, but I w I would. Um, but I mean,
I wasn't facing what you're facing being an immigrant.
So I mean, you're facing way more than I did in the, but the fact that,
uh, I don't know, you're trying to become a better person, you know, you know,
to reach out for help and all that. I th I think I,
my gut says you're going to be fine.
Well you have to do in general is when the doubt comes in,
you gotta beat the shit out of it. You know you have to, the biggest thing is,
is that you're conscious that this have the self doubt.
So once you're conscious of it, you can then address it. It's when you,
when you're really young and you're not conscious of it
and that thought comes in and then you start dwelling on it and then it just
washes over your whole body and you can literally,
you know, have a fucking panic attack.
Well you have to do, I did anyways is um,
okay.
You know, you tried to cancel it out with the positive thought.
I know this sounds like hokey shit, but I used to just say shit out loud.
I read some book one way and it started off with like,
I would just be walking down the street, you know,
walking by other people and I would just randomly just be like, yeah, fuck that.
Fuck you looking at me. Like I was nuts. But I was like,
fuck that negative thought man. Wouldn't yell it. But I would,
I would kind of just say, fuck that. Fuck that. No, it isn't. No one has it.
Right. No, it won't or whatever the hell it was. And then it just became,
like when I moved to New York
and I'm trying to get in at the clubs,
I knew I was going to get in. But you know,
if the day to day just seemed like a,
like impossible and you know, the club owners and everything and you know,
some of them were cool and others enjoyed the fact that you were desperate and
just really enjoyed that position of power over you.
And I would walk out of the club dejected,
you know, I was afraid, you know, am I gonna run out of money?
I don't have a job right now.
I'm doing these driving back to Massachusetts to fucking feature and Dick
Doherty's rooms that was not barely covering, you know,
living in New York every time you stepped outside your blue, 20 bucks, 30 bucks,
you know. And, um,
I just thought I'd started, I, what I said was, I'm tougher than you.
New York is what I would say is Hokey, is that sound. That's what they,
you know,
the city would kick me in the balls and then I would just mumble that to myself,
you know, sometimes like six times in a row
until I got that thought on my head. And I would just say,
and then I would just be like, I'm going to get in the clubs,
I'm going to get in and I'm going to make a living. I'm going to be fine.
I'm going to be fine. Everything's going to be fine. Fuck that. Fuck that.
Fuck that. I mean, something like that.
That's what I had to do. And, um,
and then it just, you know,
and that continues throughout your fucking life and, uh, you know,
then you get to my age, you know, and I'm doing great and everything,
but there's also,
there's always your mortality around the fucking corner and how I've kind of
mentally dealt with death,
the inevitable death is that like, um,
that I just think it's going to be a great experience. You know what I mean?
That, uh, I don't think anything bad happens to you when you die, either.
You just go into the ground and then that's it. And,
uh, and that's it. You know,
you got to be a person on this planet as opposed to like a fucking mosquito.
You got the best fucking experience. Hopefully you did.
Um, and then that's it.
It's fucking over or you become something else.
And I just don't think that is bad, you know?
I just don't think that it doesn't make any sense that it would then just be
bad. Um, I don't know. I hope that helps you.
I got a little off the rails there.
So what I would say is you just baby step your away,
you know? And like for me,
making it as a comedian was like a 20 year fucking 15,
20 year process. I was obviously, I was not the overnight,
I didn't have the hook, I didn't have any of that fucking shit.
And I just basically, every day, you know,
was fucking hacking at the tree until it came down. And, um,
you know, you just don't quit. You just, that's it. You just don't quit.
You don't give it a negative thought.
And every day you just fucking take a few steps towards it and then one day you
just wake up and you're way you wanted to be and you're like,
how the fuck did that happen? You know? And it was funny.
You don't feel any different, you know, so, um,
but she'll be all right. I think you're going to be alright. You know,
you speak three different fucking languages. You can break balls in English.
I mean, you sound me.
Sounded like you got a great sense of humor and you're trying to get, I,
you're going to be fine. Just say that to yourself. I'm going to be fine.
This is gonna work out and uh, then that's it.
Then you can try to fucking help somebody else out along the way. All right,
last one here. Documentary recommendations. Hey.
Oh Billy. Oh Billy. Beat down. I was wondering if you had heard of the,
this new documentary that just came up called ice guardians.
It's about the history of enforcers in hockey.
And I would love to hear your take on it if you haven't seen it.
I watch all of these fucking things. Um, I haven't seen it,
but I watched the trailer and it looked great. Um,
I don't know about the name. Ice Guardians.
That sounds somewhere between a superhero movie.
And I'm, I'm musical. I'm musical on ice.
Yeah.
Coming to Madison Square Garden. It's ice guardians.
Flossie hands skating around the ice. Um,
he said thanks for all the laughs and for always making me feel better about the
way I read things out loud. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
Here's a link to the trailer. Okay, I'll,
I'll send out this link here to the trailer. By the way. Um,
I'm going to be at the south by southwest on Tuesday.
I'm flying in Tuesday.
I'm doing a podcast with Al Madrigal for all things comedy network.
And then I'm, uh, flying right back out that night.
That's it. Boom. Doing a Po, landing, doing a podcast,
jumping back on the plane and flying back.
That's my dedication to the goddamn network and also my dedication to fucking
coming back to see my daughter. That's it. And after that, I got three days,
a Monday,
a Tuesday or Wednesday at the Improv in San Jose Cruz.
Um, and I think that that's my, uh, that'll be my fucking, uh,
that'll be my month. That's it. All right. Thanks. Listen to podcasts.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you on Thursday. And,
uh, I think that's it. That is it. All right. Go Fuck Yourself.